so sarah tweeted
uh thinking about aliens thinking about
aliens
so
how much do you think aliens are
thinking about other aliens including
humans so you said we humans want
to visit
like we're longing to connect with
aliens why is that can you introspect
that is that an obvious thing that we
should be like what are we hoping to
understand
by meeting aliens
exactly asking as an introvert it's like
i ask myself this all the time why go
out on a friday night to meet people
what are you hoping for i think
curiosity so when i saw sarah put that
tweet i think i answered it actually as
well which was uh
we are thinking about trying to make
contact so they almost certain are
certain
certainly are but maybe there's a number
of classes there are the those aliens
that have not yet made contact with
other aliens like us
those aliens have made contact with just
one other alien and maybe it's an
anti-climax and slime
right and aliens that have made contact
with not just one set of intelligent
species but several that must be amazing
actually literally there is some place
in the universe there must be one alien
civilization to not make contact with
not one
but two other intelligent civilizations
um so they must be thinking about there
must be entire
um
degree courses on aliens thinking about
aliens and cultural uh universal
cultural norms
do you think they will survive the
meeting
and by the way lee did respond saying
that's all the universe wants so sarah
said thinking about aliens thinking
about aliens they said that's all the
universe wants and then sarah responded
cheeky universe we live in
so cheeky is a cheeky version of the
word interesting all of which will try
to define
uh mathematically he might be harder
than interesting
because there's humor in that too yes
i think there's a mathematical
definition of humor but we'll talk about
that
yeah
so if you're uh a graduate student alien
looking at multiple alien civilizations
do you think they survive the encounters
i think there's a tendency to
anthropomorphize a lot of discussions
about alien life which is a really big
challenge so i usually when i'm trying
to think about these problems i don't
try to think about
us as humans but us as an example of
phenomena that exists in the universe
that we have yet to explain
and
it doesn't seem to be the case that if i
think about
the features i would argue are most
universal about that phenomena that
there's any reason to think that a first
encounter with another
lineage or
example of life would be antagonistic
um
i think
yeah and and i think there's this kind
of assumption
i mean going back to neil degrasse
tyson's uh quote i mean it kind of
bothers me because there's a i mean i'm
a physicist so i know we have a lot of
egos about how much we can describe the
world but that there's this like because
we understand fundamental physics so
well we understand
alien life and we can kind of
extrapolate and i just think that we
don't um and the quest there is really
you know really to understand something
totally new about the universe and that
thing just happens to be us i agree i
agree there's something else more
profound i think neil is just being
again he's just trying to stir the pot
i would say from a
from a contingency point of view i want
to know how many ways does the universe
build structures build memories right
that and then
i want to know if those memories and can
interact with each other and if you have
two
um
different origins of life and then
origins of intelligence and then these
things become conscious
surely you want to go and talk to them
and figure out
what commonalities you share and it
might be that we're just unable to
conceive of what they're going to look
like they're just going to be completely
different you know infrastructure
but surely we'll want to go and find out
a map and surely curiosity is a property
that evolution
has made on earth and i can't see any
reason that it won't happen elsewhere
because curiosity probably exists
because we want to find innovations in
the environment we want to use that
information to help
um our technology
and also curiosity is like planning for
the future are they going to fight us
are they are we going to be able to
trade with them so i think that neil's
just i don't know maybe
you know i mean give a [ __ ] that's
really i think that's really down on
earth right
how would aliens categorize humans do
you think
how would weak so let's put the other
way around slime category maybe no no no
we maybe we could the thing is a bit odd
right look at instagram
twitter all these people taking selfies
i mean does the universe
is the ultimate state of consciousness
thinking beings that take photographs
themselves and upload them to an
interweb with other thinking beings
looking at each other's photos so
i think that they will be wrong with
that
yeah
i did not say there was anything wrong
with it consciousness
manifested at scale yeah selfies yeah
instagram like the mirror test at scale
yeah i do think that curiosity
is really the driving force why we have
our technology right if we weren't
curious we wouldn't go out left the cave
so i think that um
so i think that neil's got it completely
wrong in fact actually of course they'd
want to come here it doesn't mean they
are coming here we've seen evidence for
that i guess we can argue about that
right
but i think that um we want i
desperately and i know that sarah does
too but i won't speak for you you're
here you can
i desperately want to have missions to
look for life in the solar system right
now i want to map life over the solar
system and then i want to understand how
we can go and find life as quickly as
possible at the nearest stars and also
at the same time do it in the lab just
to compensate
you